(audience clapping) -
All right y'all, alright
We've celebrated Rad Humans
and I have one more to close out the show.
This is What I'm Liking.
(drum rolls)(audience cheering)
It begins in a family's home
on long island, New York
tragically caught fire.
Check out these photos.
At the time, there were three people home,
including two teens and a grandma.
Unbelievably, no one was hurt
thanks to the fearless efforts
of their next door neighbor.
She helped to get
everyone out of the house,
including the family dog.
Let's get this hero on the line,
watching from NBC for New
York, say hi to Antonina.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Hi. Oh no we love having you.
Thank you for being a part of the show.
So you saw this from your
backyard, is that right?
- Yes. I saw this.
I was setting up for
my sister's grad party.
My best friend looked up and was like,
"Oh my God", like I just ran over.
I wasn't thinking. I ran
to go in the backyard.
It was already too far. I
just ran into the house.
I let everyone know what happened.
And it just, it was hectic.
It was really crazy.
- [Kelly] Imagine, that
fire looked enormous.
- [Antonina] Yeah it is.
- [Kelly] Yeah. And scary.
So running into it,
-[Antonina] It was scary
- I wouldn't imagine
- was the first thing I would do. Yeah.
That would have scared me.
So, and if that wasn't already amazing,
you did one more thing for
the family. What was it?
- [Antonina] I decided to start
a GoFundMe for the family,
which raised already over $75,000.
(audience clapping) - [Kelly] Wow.
- After all that,
it was heartbreaking to
me that that happened.
I couldn't imagine. You think
that something like that
will never happen to you.
And then it happens to
people you're close to
it happens to your neighborhood.
And it's insane to think about.
So I started the GoFundMe.
You know, we're all displaced after this.
My family has been displaced after this.
My, we were living in an RV, then a hotel.
Now we're still separated,
but I'm happy that everyone is alive.
No one was hurt and I'm happy
that I was able to do
that for their family.
And I'm happy, you know,
(audience clapping)
it's a terrible situation,
but I'm just so glad that
this is how it turned out
rather than anything else.
Cause I couldn't imagine, you know,
what if I, what if we
weren't outside setting up.
It would probably be very, very terrible.
- [Kelly] Yeah absolutely. Well,
thank you so much Antonina,
like that's such a beautiful
thing you did for this family.
Also, I have to say your eyes
are the most captivating,
beautiful eyes I've ever seen.
So I just have to tell you that
- [Antonina] Oh thank you so much.
- [Kelly] I'm also liking
your post right now. Right?
- [Antonina] Oh, thank you.
- Well, that's not all our
season long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show
thinks your quick action
is as incredible as we do.
So they'll be using their
friction erasable pen
to write you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Thank you so much.
- [Kelly] Nah absolutely,
thank you so much for joining us girl.